you are about to learn about the popular
statistical application
spss from ibm this course from
university professor barton paulson
will show you how you can use spss to
explore your data for actionable
insights
welcome to spss an introduction i'm
barton poulson and in this course
we're going to look at the statistical
program spss
and some of its basic functionality and
give you an idea of what it can do
and how well it might work in your own
data work
now spss the name deserves a little bit
of explanation
once upon a time it stood for
statistical package for the social
sciences now it's just spss but that's
its origin
one important thing to know is how
popular spss is
here's a chart right here that comes
from the excellent website r4stats.com
and what it shows is the number of
scholarly articles published in 2015
using various statistical packages and
languages
and what you can see here is right at
the top is sps statistics
spss is number one by far in terms of
scholarly research also you can look at
jobs here's another chart that is also
from
r4stats.com and what this shows is
analytics
job listings on indeed.com in 2015.
one major source of tech jobs sps is on
the list but this time you see it's
actually a lot lower it's
number six and so there is a difference
here
between academic publishing and
employment in analytics really what this
tells you something about the population
or the audience for spss
the primary audience of spss is academic
researchers
especially in the social sciences but in
other fields like business
now there's some reasons that spss is
popular in these fields
number one it's user friendly it's got a
point-and-click interface which allows
you to assemble code really quickly
you can save that code as what's called
a syntax file
and then you can reuse it you can adapt
it and you can share it with others
also spss is really well adapted for
data from
experiments where you're comparing means
via t-tests and analysis of variance
with several important options like
effect sizes and power analysis built in
and so those are some of the reasons for
spss popularity especially within
academic research
in some we can say a few things number
one spss
despite being developed about 40 years
ago is still popular
it's got an easy to use interface and
it's easy to save and reuse the syntax
giving you a code basis for the work
that you do within spss
the first thing we need to talk about in
spss an introduction is
setting up and getting ready to do the
work to do that however
we need to take a minute and talk about
versions editions
and modules which all refer to different
kinds of things in spss
the choice is really making me think of
an overwhelming
plethora of possibilities ahead of you
and
it's nice to break it down a little bit
so the things we're going to talk about
are
versions those are the release updates
you know version 1 version 2.
additions those vary according to what's
included
in a particular purchase and modules are
extra functions that you can get to
add on to the abilities of spss we'll
start by talking about
versions version 1 came out in 1968 and
at that point it was called statistical
package for the social sciences
spss version 24
came out in 2016 and now it's called ibm
spss statistics they act like spss
doesn't stand for anything
now for this course i'm using version 22
on a macintosh computer
fortunately there haven't been any
extraordinarily major changes between 22
and 24 and everything i'm going to show
you in this course will work
just fine in almost any other version of
spss
now it is possible that you've heard of
something called p-a-s-w
at some point and spss
was briefly called predictive analytics
software
during a trademark dispute after spss
got bought by ibm
that only lasted for a year or so and it
got resolved
the important thing to know is that no
matter what version you're using the
files
generally are highly compatible between
versions
and so code that you created in version
16 is probably readable in version 24.
there are some backwards compatibility
issues for advanced functions like
automatic modeling and so on
but most of it is consistent all the way
through
now we also need to talk about additions
of spss
and there are a few major choices here
there's the base edition
the standard edition the professional
edition
and the premium edition
and they differ by price and they differ
by the functions that are
included with each addition so for
example
in base you get basic statistics you get
linear regression
you get clustering and factor analysis
on the other hand standard adds on to
that
logistic regression generalized linear
models
and survival analysis
it also adds drag and drop interactive
tables
the professional addition adds to that
data prep forecasting decision trees
and imputation methods and then finally
the top of the line premium
edition of spss adds bootstrapping
complex sampling
exact tests and structural equation
modeling
and so each one adds on a number of
other functions
now this is the product pricing as of
august of 2016 and you see for instance
that spss starts in the base at one
thousand one hundred and seventy dollars
per year per person so it's an annual
license
and it goes all the way up to nearly
eight thousand dollars
per user per year and so it gets really
expensive
however i want to say this don't panic
there are other ways aside from having
to like you know
sell your house to get spss number one
there is a free trial
and you can download spss and you can
try it for 14 days
and during that time the best way to do
this is see if you can make a business
case and get somebody else to buy it for
you
there is also academic pricing student
pricing for spss starts at 35 dollars
for
six months it's not the super duper
version but it is
absolutely sufficient for doing the
majority
of academic research now we also need to
talk about
modules and these are the components
that add
extra functionality to spss and they're
the things that differentiate the
different editions primarily
modules of rephrase the available
modules include advanced statistics
bootstrapping categories complex samples
conjoint custom tables data preparation
decision trees direct marketing exact
tests forecasting
missing values neural networks and
regression
so that's 14 additional modules and this
sounds like a lot but if you can compare
it to the
9000 packages that are available for r
there's a difference there the other
major difference is that
these packages they cost money
so you need to work that into your
budget on the other hand
there are also free plug-ins that make
it possible to use
code in r python java
and the microsoft.net framework within
spss
and so there are abilities that you can
add depending on
what you need in sum we can say this
spss has a long history as far as
statistical software goes
there are several variations and
additional
rephrase there are several variations
and additions that you can make to it
by adding extra modules on the other
hand it can be very pricey so it's
something to consider
when you're doing the cost-benefit
analysis of spss
the next step in spss and introduction
and setting up
is simply taking a look at spss and
seeing what the program's like
and the easiest way to do that is to
just open it up
when you first open spss you'll get this
introductory splash screen
that gives you an opportunity to open up
some files recent files and learn more
about various things that you can get
from spss
if you want to you can click on this box
don't show this dialogue in the future
then you won't have to deal with it
again you can also just press cancel
and that brings you to the data window
in spss which has
a lot in common with a spreadsheet it
has these rows and columns
where you have one row per case and one
column per variable
but there are some very important
differences between
spss and a spreadsheet to demonstrate
this i'm going to open up a data set
that i've used recently
and then when this opens up you see that
it does resemble a spreadsheet we have
the variable names
across the top we have row numbers down
the bottom and we have data
in the middle now one important
difference between
spss data window and a spreadsheet is
this
you have a data view but you also have
something called a variable view
and it's the same data set but if we
click on it we see it in a different way
each of the variables has metadata
associated with it so for instance
age it tells you the type of the
variable now these are mostly numeric
there's a string variable but you can
see there's a lot of choices here
numeric comma dot and so on
you also can specify the width of the
variable the number of decimal places
and then a really important thing that
makes spss different from most other
programs is the use of
labels this column right here shows
variable labels and the idea is we have
a short one word variable name
over here on the left and if you use a
very old version of spss they were
limited to
eight characters and you ended up
sometimes with very cryptic names
you don't have quite the same
restrictions anymore but what's common
is to give a short name to the variable
and then to give it a label that is more
descriptive
in addition you can have value labels so
let's come here to marital
and we click on this and this is a way
of telling spss
that in that column zero means unmarried
and one
means married obviously you can make
them whatever you want
and when you come back here you have the
option of seeing them
so i'm going to come right up here and
i'm going to click on this one
which will show the value labels and you
see how they've appeared now
i can have them go away
and are the variables if i just hover
over then i see the longer name
going back to variable view you can also
specify values
for missing values you can give the
width of the column
the alignment and then you can specify
the
scale of the rephrase
and then you can specify the level of a
measurement now spss uses
three values scale which is a interval
or ratio level measured variable
ordinal which is ranked data and nominal
which is categories
you also have the option of specifying
whether something is an input variable
a target variable or both and
there are certain functions that use
those but most of the time that's not a
big deal and you see that in this
demonstration data set
those haven't been changed at all
so the first window in spss is this data
window
but there's more to spss than that
so for instance let's make a very quick
graph i'm just going to make a simple
chart here we'll come and make a
histogram
of age and hit ok
and so you see i have a graphical user
interface with drag and drop menus that
allows me
to assemble my commands this way i hit
ok
and then what we get is another window
that opens up it's
super tiny up here so i'm going to make
it much bigger
and this is the output window so it's a
separate window the data is in one
window
and when you do an analysis you get a
separate output window you can actually
have multiple output windows
and what this one does is it has the
graphs or any statistical analyses we do
it also has a table of contents over
here that you can collapse things or you
can expand
them and an
important thing is i've got it set so it
shows the code that spss
generates behind the scenes to create
this analysis and the neat thing about
that is you can actually use that code
and you can manipulate it directly
this code is called syntax in spss
now by default spss opens up
only a data window and an output window
but you can get a syntax window as well
so in fact let me do that i'm going to
come up to file
new and syntax
and this is a very blank window but it's
one that you can type in
or you can also use the drop down menus
to put a command in there
so i'm going to come back here to the
recent command
and i did a histogram and i could press
ok again but now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to press
paste and what that's going to do is is
going to get
the code for that chart and it's going
to put it right here
in fact this is the part that we use
and if i select that i can hit run
i can also do command or control r
it runs the selection and you'll see we
get the output window again
and it's done the exact same thing a
second time but this time it did it from
a window
where i'm able to have the text now a
lot of people are uncomfortable with
syntax and they like the drag and drop
menus
but a really important thing about this
is it allows you to
save your analysis so you can repeat it
again
without having to go through all the
menus you can simply
paste the syntax from the dialogs
into a syntax file and then you can
repeat it as many times as you want it's
also really easy to modify
things when you do it that way and
syntax files are just
plain text files they're saved with a
dot spss extension
but they read just like plain text files
now these are the most important
elements of the spss
environment the data window with both
the data and the variable view
the output windows and the syntax
windows that allow you to save the
commands
and this is what gives spss both some of
its flexibility
and its power and as you become more
comfortable
moving back and forth between these
various windows and seeing what you're
able to do
both with the drag and drops and by
typing text you'll discover there's a
great amount of flexibility and power in
spss that can allow you
to do the analyses you need to do and
get the insight you want from your data
we'll continue our introduction and
discussion of setting up an spss
by taking a look at the sample data that
comes as part of the spss application
the really nice thing about that is it
allows you to get started now and start
working with things and see how spss
works
the hard part however is that it's
totally hidden
and so you need to know where to look in
order to use the sample data
now if you're on a macintosh like i am
then it's going to be in your
applications folder
under ibm spss statistics 22 or whatever
version you're using
then samples and then in english then
you'll have them
in windows it's a little bit different
it's going to be
c program files ibm spss statistics
22 or whatever version you have samples
and then english
so you have to navigate to that manually
in order to be able to find those but
when you do you'll see a bunch of files
there now there's a few kinds in
particular that are important
there are the dot sav files these are
data files in the proprietary spss
format
they can only be opened up in spss
usually
and there are also dot sbs files and
these are spss
syntax files they're text files with the
commands that can run a number of
analyses and graphs and other functions
in spss
now we can try it in spss by having you
on your computer open up the window and
opening up a file called demo
dot save but let me show you how it
works
when you navigate to the folder with the
spss sample files in it again it's
several hidden layers down these are the
files that you'll find these are the dot
sav data files and these are
the spss syntax files now there are
other things in there there's something
called a csa plan that's an analysis
plan
there's an xml file and there's a few
other things in there
but the majority of what we want to deal
with in fact
rephrase but the only ones that we're
going to deal with are the dot
sav files and possibly the spss files
let's scroll down here until we find
demo dot
save now please note there's a lot of
other demo files around that so you want
this one in particular demo.sav because
that's the
spss file i'm going to double click on
that
and spss opens up the file now you can
set spss so it has only one data file
open at a time or you can have multiples
i'm going to close this empty file right
here
but here is our demo file and this
allows us to start
working with a lot of the analyses and
see how they work in fact
i'll be using this file all the way
through this entire course
because it allows you to do a number of
analyses
that require specific kinds of data and
this has it all set up
so i'll show you a very quick one i'm
going to come up to
analyze and to explore
and i will get level of education and
put that in
and so i have a long list of variables
that i can work with these are all the
same variables
i'll just hit ok and that opens up
my output window again it opens up
microscopically here
in the top corner so i'm going to make
it bigger
and now i'm able to start working with
my sample data and that allows me to get
some hands-on experience
to see how the functions work in spss
and to try some of the options and see
how they affect things
our next step in spss and introduction
is to look at basic
graphics because those are always a good
first step in analysis
and the easiest way to do that in spss
is with something called graph board
templates really you can just think of
these as graphs made
easy the idea here is that if you set
the levels of measurement
in spss then spss can suggest
graphs that would be appropriate for
those variables
now in terms of level of measurement
remember spss uses three
number one is nominal for different
categories
number two is ordinal for ranks
and number three is scales that's for
interval or ratio level measurements
and then when you're in the graph board
templates you have two basic choices
you have basic graphs and those are
where you choose the variables
first that you want to graph and then
spss will show you suggested graphs you
can see what you want to do with them
there's also an option for detailed and
this is where you choose the graph style
first
and then you choose the variables that
go into it
now these aren't exclusive you can
bounce back and forth between the two
tabs
and it'll be easiest to see how it works
if we just go to spss
if you're logged into datalab.cc then
you should be able to download the
exercise files from the same page that
this video is on
open up this file spsso1 underscore 3
underscore one underscore graphboard.sps
it's a syntax file and let's see what it
looks like
syntax file that you've opened looks
kind of complicated but this is really
because i want to have a written record
of the same things that we're going to
do with the drag and drop menus in the
graph board
we do need to open a data set and as i
mentioned before
depending on whether you're on a
macintosh or on a windows computer
the path to the data sets is a little
bit different and
also depending on the version you're
using i'm using 22
and so if you're using something else
change that number right there most of
it should be the same
and you can run this command and open up
the data set and activate it now i've
already done that
i'll show you there's my data set right
there's the demo.save
and we can come down here to variable
view
and see the levels of measurement that
spss has assigned to these
most of them are scale we have a few
that are ordinal we have only
one variable in this data set that's
truly coded as
nominal and that's gender which is
actually a string variable in this case
i'll go back to the syntax
now i have some rather complicated
syntax here but what you'll see
is that when we use the menus it's
actually pretty simple
the first thing we're going to do is
make a chart of
age but i'm going to come up here to
graphs
to the graph board template chooser
and when i come to that you see i'm in
this tab of basic graphs and this is
where i choose a variable
i'm going to choose age right here and
it recommends three different kinds of
charts a dot plot a histogram and a
histogram with a normal distribution
we'll take the very first one that's
available dot plot and hit ok
it puts it in the output window which i
have to maximize and there it is it's a
dot plot looks a lot like a histogram
of age in years so it goes down to 18
years it looks like it goes up to about
77 78 and it's an easy way to get a feel
of the distribution that we're dealing
with
again the command in text and syntax
is complicated but the graphical
interface makes this very easy to do
i'll go back to the syntax for a moment
if you were to paste the syntax for that
command this is what you would see right
here and it's a way of saving it and you
can modify it manually if you want
now we'll do a histogram of age with a
superimposed normal distribution
again i'll come up to graphs to graph
board template chooser
and this time all i have to do is come
over to the right
i click histogram with normal
distribution and hit ok
expand the output window and it's really
simple
now both of those charts that i showed
you were with age which is a
ratio level or scaled variable in spss
terminology
we can also do this with categorical
variables i'll use
gender and make a bar chart come back up
to graphs
hit graph board template chooser and
when i come down to gender you'll see
that the
recommended charts change because this
time it knows it's a categorical
variable
now if i had gps data i could put that
in here i can do a bunch of different
things i'm just going to do a bar chart
because that's the easiest to deal with
i'll hit ok
make the output window bigger there's my
bar chart and you see that in this
particular data set we have
an almost exactly equal number of men
and women
or data on them
now those were the basic charts where
you choose the variable first and spss
recommends particular graphs
you can also do detailed charts these
are ones where you choose the style of
chart first and then you fill in the
variables
i'm going to do this again for a dot
plot of income and then show you that
it's really easy to modify it
i'll come up to graphs to graph board
template chooser
this time i'll go to the detailed tab
click on that
and i'm going to make a dot plot
so i'm going to scroll through this you
see we have a lot of choices
i'm going to choose dot plot and then
it's going to ask what i want to make a
dot plot
of i'm going to click on this
and i'm going to scroll to income
see the one that i want is right here
household income in thousands
i can click ok
and then expand the output window
and here's my chart it's a really basic
chart and you see
that most of the people are at the low
end especially because this is hundreds
of thousands of dollars so that's going
to be a million dollars right there
but i want to show you an interesting
thing about this if we double click on
the chart
that opens up the edit window and the
graph board editor has some special
options
for one thing i can change the number of
decimal places here i just click on the
decimals
come to format and change the minimum
level
or rather the minimum number of decimals
to zero
that's better but a more interesting one
is if i click on the
dots themselves they're done as points
and the modifier is to pile them there
are a few other modifiers that can be
useful
one is to dodge them and what that does
is it puts them in the middle expanding
out either way
it might be a little harder to make
comparisons from one
level to another but it's an interesting
kind of chart
i can click on it again and we can do
what's called
jitter with a normal distribution
and that takes points with the same
value and it kind of randomly spreads
them out up and down
and again you can see that we've got a
whole lot there at the bottom
one other choice is jitter uniform which
makes them stay within certain
boundaries
but it's hard to tell really how much
things are spread out there at the
bottom so i actually prefer
pile or i think dodge is interesting in
this case
and so that's one way of using graph
board to both
set it up and then to manually modify it
by double clicking on the chart
i can close this because i'm done with
that and you see i have the modified
version right there
now we can get a lot more complicated
so for instance i can make a scatter
plot of age and income with colors for
point density
there's a lot of options and you can
explore them this time i'm going to do a
little bit differently i'm just going to
select this command and again the way i
got these was by setting them up in the
menus and then
simply hitting paste and it put the
syntax
into this syntax file so i could save it
and run it later and so i'm going to
show you how that works
i've got the command here that i created
using the graph board template chooser
and i'll simply come up and select run
selection
and i maximize that window and there you
can see i actually have what's called
a hex scatter plot and it's showing
a few different things and it's a really
neat way and so you have a lot of
options on the way you display things in
the graph board template chooser
and while the code is complicated the
interaction
with the menus is really simple you can
be creative and you can get different
views on your data and try to get more
insight as you're doing your analysis
the next step in our introduction to
spss and basic graphics is bar charts
and we like bar charts for a very simple
reason they are simple and
simple is good or more specifically
bar charts are the most basic graphic
for the
most basic data just frequencies for a
simple category
it's also a very basic command in spss
now we actually have a few options on
different kinds of bar charts
one we can make a simple bar chart so a
single variable
simply showing the category frequencies
in that variable
two we can do a grouped bar chart where
we
break it down by some other variable and
then three
we can do multiple variables and show
the bars
simultaneously but let's try this in
spss it's really easy to do
just open up this spss syntax file
and we'll give it a whirl once you've
got the file open you'll need to open
the demo data set
we've used it before this is the command
for mac
if you're running 22 and this is the
command for windows if you're running 22
just change the version number if you
need to
once you have the file open we're going
to make some bar graphs
now i'm going to do it by coming up here
to what are called the legacy dialogues
these are
specialized one graph only dialogues
that come from earlier versions of spss
and truthfully i
usually use these because i find them so
quick and easy to deal with
what we're going to do is we're going to
make a bar chart for levels of education
in our sample
so i'm going to hit bar we're going to
do a simple bar chart
and we'll do groups of cases
and all i need to do is hit level of
education
put it into the category axis
and hit ok
and i make the output bigger there it is
absolute piece of cake and it's also
very very simple syntax you see the
syntax right here it's
really could be one line and just
as a point of comparison
here's the same chart produced with the
chart builder but you see we have this
really complicated
overwhelming code the legacy chart
produces it an extremely simple way so
that's a simple bar chart
piece of cake now let's do a clustered
bar chart for groups of cases we'll look
at
levels of education by gender to do that
we come back up to graphs
into legacy dialogues to bar
and now we're going to cluster it we're
going to do a level of education
clustered by gender so i hit define
and we've got level of education that's
sort of our outcome variable
put that under category axis and then
define clusters by
gender let me put that right there i'll
hit ok
and make it bigger and this time it uses
nicer colors
but you have the five levels of
education broken down
where women are in blue men are in green
but it's really easy to see here
the relationship between the two
variables and in this particular data
set it really looks like there's no
substantial difference between the men
and women now i'll say
i believe this is an artificial data set
so we wouldn't expect a lot of
differences
but this is a nice way to compare them
by the way come up and you'll see that
the code for this is
really simple all it does is it adds by
gender
and so again a very short command
i'm going to go back to the syntax and
we're going to do one more here and that
is for
multiple variables so
this is a situation in which it can be
confusing if you have
a lot of categories within each variable
what i'm doing here
is i'm going to get the means of
variables or the numbers of
ones if you have an indicator variable
where zero for no and a one for yes
this is a really nice way of comparing
the frequencies of each one of them
across i'll show you how that works
we'll go up to graphs
we'll come back over to bar and we're
going to do a simple
one but this time we're doing separate
variables i'll hit define
then i'm going to come down here and
this data set
again which i believe is fictional asked
a lot of people about
various things that they might do
we're going to ask them about
wireless service and we're going to come
down to whether they own a fax machine
because this is
old data and it's asking about old
technology pagers i've never had a pager
but i simply select all those variables
i put them in here
and as long as they're all on the same
scale it's going to do the mean of each
one
and on the 0 1 the mean is the
proportion of ones
i hit ok
and there we have it it's a way of
looking at the distribution of
multiple variables simultaneously it's a
very information
dense display and especially when you as
an analyst are exploring your data
this can be a really quick and easy way
of getting a feel for your data which
can then direct your further analyses
as we continue to look at basic graphics
in spss a really common one
is histograms and this is a graphic for
data that is
quantitative or scaled or measured
or interval or ratio level those really
all are referring to basically the same
thing
and in any of them you're going to want
to make a histogram
to see what the variable is like now
i'll mention that spss prefers the term
scale for these variables and that's
what shows up in the data definitions
and i like to think of it as the scales
of justice
but why are we making a histogram
the point is to see what you have to see
what the data's like and there's a few
things in particular that you're going
to be looking for
number one you're going to be looking
for the shape of the distribution is it
unimodal bimodal
skewed left skewed right are there gaps
in the data that suggests that maybe you
have some
important mechanism operating are there
outliers that you would need to
take consideration of before you do your
analysis is your data symmetrical
there are a lot of different things that
you could look for and some of these are
going to have a lot of influence on your
analyses so
it's important to take a look at the
data and histogram will give you a great
impression of a quantitative or scaled
variable
we'll try it in spss simply open up this
syntax file
and we'll see how it works when you're
in spss
most of this is really just to open up
the data sets the same one we've used in
the others this demo data set
and here's the code for mac adjust the
version number if you need to and here's
the code for windows
but once you have the data set open you
can use the commands and it's really
really
simple all you need to do is come up to
graphs we'll go to legacy dialogs and
we'll come down here to the bottom to
histogram
and we're going to make a basic
histogram of age
so i click that and i come to age it's
our first variable
and i simply click this to move it over
and hit ok
i'll make the output window bigger and
there's our histogram
and from this we can see that our
distribution is unimodal
we can see it's pretty close to normal
it's slightly skewed on the high end
but not very much and this is going to
be a really
good variable for most of our analyses
because it meets most of the assumptions
of the kinds of procedures we might want
to use
now if i want to make things slightly
more complicated because you see that
the command for this
is extremely simple
we can make a small modification i'll
show you here
we can superimpose a normal distribution
and all i have to do for that is come
back to graphs
to legacy dialogs into histogram
and i just check this box right here
display normal curve
and what that's going to do is it's
going to create the same distribution
but it's going to put on top of it a
line of a
bell curve or normal distribution that
has the same mean and standard deviation
and here you can see we're pretty close
to normal and this is a nice way of
confirming that
and again the code for it is really
simple all it does
is it adds the word normal in this
sentence and that gives us everything we
need it's one of the reasons i really
like the legacy dialogues in spss
is because it's so concise it's so
simple and it gets you what you need
so you can get a grip of your data and
move ahead
as we continue spss and introduction and
basic graphics
we should look at scatter plots a very
common method of looking at associations
or as i like to think as way of
assessing togetherness
in data in other words you want to see
what goes with what or more specifically
what
variable goes with what other variable
so scatter plots are a great way of
visualizing the association between
two quantitative variables when you make
a scatter plot there are some things you
should look for
and in case you're wondering what they
are they include for instance
whether the association between the two
variables is linear
because a lot of the procedures that are
common assume that you can draw a
straight line through the data
you want to check the spread of the data
especially whether the spread
changes as you go from left to right on
a scatter plot that's called
heterogeneity of variance and it can
cause problems with certain procedures
you want to look for outliers either
univariate that's a score that's unusual
on a single variable by itself
or in this case what's even more
significant is bivariate where you have
an unusual combination of scores
and then finally you want to try to get
some idea for the correlation or the
strength of the association between the
two variables
and scatter plot will allow you to do
all of those now in spss
there are three general kinds of scatter
plots that you can do
number one is a simple scatter it's a
bivariate x and y chart
easy to do number two is a matrix
scatter plot where you actually have
several
variables in there simultaneously and
it's a good way of looking at complex
associations between collections of
variables
and number three spss is able to do a 3d
scatter plot but i'll have some words to
say about that a little bit later
but let's try this and see how scatter
plots work in spss at least
very basically so just open up this
syntax file and we can see how it works
when you open up the syntax file we have
the same situation where you can load
the data
we'll use demo.save and you can use this
command if you're on a mac
using version 22 and this command on
windows version 22.
but we're just going to make a couple of
scatter plots and it's a really basic
easy command the first thing we're going
to do is make a scatter plot of age and
income
but let's come up to graphs to legacy
dialogues
and down to scatter
i'm going to use a simple scatter that's
just a basic bivariate xy chart i'll hit
define
and all i need to do here is pick my
variables for the x-axis
across the bottom and the y-axis up the
side
i'm going to pick age for the x-axis and
put it right there
and household income for the y-axis and
the idea is
maybe there's an association between
household income and how old a person is
that's all i need to do except click ok
and when i get that i get this basic
scatter plot
so i have age and years across the
bottom i have household income and
thousands up the side
and you can see of course that most of
the people are near the bottom that's
because most people make less than two
hundred thousand dollars a year
this graph goes up to 1.2 million
we have a marker that's a large empty
circle it's in black and you can change
the markers and there's things you can
do to clean up the chart
but it's also easy to tell the people
who for instance make a lot of money
are generally older and so we can see
in this data there is some kind of
association between
age and income but let's try to get a
more
nuanced one by looking at several
variables simultaneously with a
scatterplot matrix
come back up to graphs and legacy
dialogs and down to scatter
this time however i'm going to pick
matrix scatter
click define and then all i need to do
is pick the variables i want to include
i don't have to specify x or y because
they're all going to serve as both x and
y in different parts of the matrix
i'm going to pick a few here i'm going
to get household income i'll move it
over
i will get age move that over
i'll get address years at current
address
move that over i'll get reside which is
the number of people
residing in the house move that and then
finally i'll get level of education
there's nothing especially meaningful
about these they're just ones that i
thought would be easy to look at
now as a general recommendation if you
do have one variable
that is an outcome variable you might
want to put that one in first that puts
it in the first column in the first row
and it makes it easier to find it when
you're looking at your analyses
but i've got my five variables in there
and i just come and press ok
takes a moment and then i come up
and this is the scatter plot matrix and
so you have all five variables listed on
the side you have all five variables
listed across the bottom so each one
functions as both an x and a y
you have empty boxes down the diagonal
because that would be each variable with
itself and
the correlation is always one now
there are things you can do to clean
this up you can change the marker from a
big
black circle to something that's smaller
and easier to see you can put
regression lines through but it's easy
to see that there's some really
important patterns
so for instance age in years
and years at current address right here
obviously there's a limit
you can't live someplace longer than
you've been alive that's why we have
nothing in the top left of that
but you do see some associations and
some cutoffs that go through
now this one's really dense in a lot of
situations
it's going to be a lot easier to see the
patterns that's there
especially if you change the markers and
put in regression lines but this gives a
good idea of what you can do with a
scatterplot matrix
now let's go back one more time to the
legacy dialogues
and to scatter because you saw that
there were other options there
there's a dot plot that's like a
histogram and there's an overlay scatter
which
i don't want to deal with and then
there's a 3d scatter and you might look
at that go like
cool it's interactive it's 3d it's a
great thing i'm actually not even going
to do it because
every time i've done a 3d diagram i've
found it's impossible to read it clearly
it's very hard to manipulate in spss and
it ends up being
really a bad experience and it's much
easier to look at the association
between variables
using a scatter plot matrix that's why i
recommend that you avoid the 3d
completely
even though it's available here but
avoid it completely
and use the bivariate and the
scatterplot matrices as a way of looking
at the associations between variables in
your data
once you've done the basic graphics for
your data and seeing what you're dealing
with it's a good idea to move on to
basic statistics
and in spss the most basic version of
this is frequencies
i like to think of it as putting things
into buckets
and then simply counting what's in the
buckets
so the idea is when you have a limited
number of categories in your data
then you should just count how often
each category occurs
it's a first step to really some
significant insight
but wait i just want to mention that the
frequencies command
in spss can do so much more than that
and i'm going to show you how it works
for example it can do charts it can do
bar charts and pie charts and histograms
and normal distributions
and they can do a lot of statistics
beyond frequencies it can do
quartiles percentiles mean median mode
standard deviation
variance skewness kurtosis and so on in
fact because of this i like to think of
frequencies as spss version of the
competent man character in literature
and movies
who can do everything well you know
somebody like
leonardo da vinci or iron man who seems
to be able to do everything or you know
marie curie right here because
she won two nobel prizes and what have
the rest of us done
but anyhow back to statistics let's take
a look at frequencies and let's try it
in spss
just open up this syntax file and we'll
see the things that it's able to do for
you
as always we need to begin by opening a
data set we'll use demo.save
and you can use this command in mac or
this command in windows to do that
once you have the data set open it's a
very simple thing to get the frequencies
now i have the syntax saved here
but really it's more as a record of what
i've done because i use the drop down
menus to create these commands
so i'm going to come up to frequencies
and i'm going to get the frequencies for
gender
and job satisfaction to do that i come
to analyze
to descriptive statistics and then the
first option there is frequencies
and what i'm going to get is gender
which is right here i'll just double
click to move it over
and we'll also get job satisfaction i'll
double click and move that over
now what's important is these are two
different kinds of variables
gender is a categorical variable nominal
and job satisfaction here is a scaled
variable and so
normally you don't do the same kinds of
things for these but frequencies is very
flexible
so i'm just going to hit ok and we'll
see the default output for frequencies
the first thing that it shows us is how
many
valid observations are so how many of
our 6400 cases have data on these
variables
the answer is all of them there's no
missing data here and then it comes down
and it gives us frequency
tables where it lists every value
or possible score on the variable and
then says how often each one occurs
so for gender we have 3179
female respondents that's 49.7 percent
and the percent and the valid percent
would be different if we had
missing data but we don't so we can
ignore that and then the cumulative
simply adds up to 100
and then job satisfaction this is a
scaled variable which has
one two three four five as answers
and here you can see how many people put
each of the answers
17 highly dissatisfied 21.8 neutral
19.1 highly satisfied
and that's a quick look at the
frequencies that we're dealing with it's
a nice way also to check if your
variables are coded well
but what we can do is more than that we
can also
turn off the tables and we can do bar
charts
using the frequencies command so i'm
going to keep those same two variables
gender and job satisfaction
but this time i'm just going to make bar
charts i'll go back to my recent
commands frequencies and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to click this
it's going to give me a little error
message because i haven't changed the
other thing first
i'm going to come to charts right here
i'm and tell it to make bar
charts obviously it can make pie charts
and histograms as well
i'll click continue and then click ok
and now the same general command
frequencies is
not producing tables but it's producing
charts and here you can see that we are
very closely matched in terms of the
number of male and female respondents
and here you can see job satisfaction
sort of peaks at neutral and somewhat
satisfied
and so that's a really nice thing you
don't even have to use the bar chart
command you can do it right here
you can also get more kinds of
statistics
in there so for instance this one i'm
going to keep the tables off but i'm
going to ask for a few extra things
in fact let me just come back to this
one
we'll go to analyze descriptives
and frequencies
and this time i'm going to do age reside
and job sat
so i'm going to remove my one
categorical variable here
i'll just reset that i'll do age
or the other two reside and job sat
and then i think that's this one right
here
and we'll come down to job satisfaction
and we'll move that over so i have three
variables but they're all scaled
variables
what i'm going to do here is first i'm
going to come to statistics
and i have really an impressive range of
things i can get
i can get the mean i can get the median
the mode if you want the mode i think
this is the only place to get it in spss
i can get quartile values now it doesn't
do the minimum and the maximum you have
to
select those separately down here
but you can also get cut points now a
cup point's an interesting one
the quartiles are cut point it splits
the data into four equal size groups
with the same number of people in each
sometimes you want something other than
that so for instance i know that if
you're doing propensity scores
it's not uncommon to use five equal
groups quintiles
and also there are situations in which
you want not
the most extreme scores but near the
most and so i'm going to put for
instance the 2.5 percentile
and then 97.5 percentile because those
frame the middle 95
of the data i can also get the standard
deviation in the variance
and is there anything else i want right
here
i want skewness and kurtosis
i'm going to hit continue then i'm going
to come back to this one i'm going to
turn off the frequency tables because
otherwise i have a lot of different
possible answers here i have a lot
going on i'll hit charts and this time
i'm going to ask for histograms and
we'll put a normal curve
on top of each histogram click continue
and click ok
and so here's what we get it starts with
the statistical output here are the
three variables i selected it gives us
the mean
the standard deviation the variance
skewness and standard error of skewness
kurtosis
we have the minimum and maximum scores
and then the percentiles now it's a
funny list here because i've got three
things intermingled i have
the quartiles that's something i asked
for so we have the 25th percentile
the 50th percentile and the 75th
percentile those are the quartile values
i had the minimum and maximum up here so
those are the zero and 100
quartiles but i also asked for quintiles
and so that splits it at
20 40 60 and 80 percent
and then finally i manually entered the
two and a half percentile and then 97
and a half percentile
and so they're all put there together
but it's really easy to see
the changes in the distribution beneath
that we have the histograms
and we have each variable has its own
histogram along with
a normal distribution with the same mean
and standard deviation laid on top
age is pretty close to normal here's a
current address however you can see is
really skewed because most people
haven't lived there that long and then
finally job satisfaction is a little
flatter than
we would expect if it were normally
distributed the point of this is that
i'm able to do a tremendous amount of
statistical and graphical work
using a single command the frequencies
function
in spss one of the most versatile
commands you'll ever use
in our previous movie we looked at the
power of the frequencies command but for
basic statistics another very common
choice
is descriptives within spss the neat
thing about descriptives is it allows
you to achieve
maximum density that is
how to get a lot of numbers on a lot of
variables
in just a little space that's what
descriptives is really good for
on the other end there is a restriction
it works only with numerical variables
but that's a lot of the data that you
might have
and if you have that it can give you
things like the mean
the sum the standard deviation the
standard
error the variance the minimum and
maximum the range the skewness
and kurtosis you know i say but guess
what you know
in case you don't remember frequencies
does more but that's okay
there are certain things that the
descriptives command does well
here's what it does well first it gives
you
very concise compact tabular output
so it's really easy to see a bunch of
information in a small space
second it's a really quick way to find
obvious errors in coding in your data
finally you can get proportions for
indicator variables that's
zero one variables and i'll show you how
that works
also we have a bonus feature here in
descriptives descriptives is the home of
spss
top secret hidden one-step z-score
procedure
i've seen people knock themselves out
trying to get z-scores by getting
standard deviations and means
you don't have to do any of that you
click one button and you're done
but let's try it in spss and i'll show
you how it works just open up this
syntax file
and we'll see what you can do with
descriptives
we'll begin as always by opening the
data set we'll be using demo.save
here's the path on a macintosh running
version 22
and the path on a window is also running
version 22.
this is my first command and it looks
really long but that's because i have a
lot of variables in it
all we need to do is come up to analyze
to descriptive statistics and
descriptives
we click on that now one of the things
it does is it only shows you the
variables that it can
analyze so gender which was a string
variable
meaning it had just text that's not in
there but what i
can do is i can just select all of them
and do a command or control
a and then move everything over
and then i'm just going to do the
default analysis i'll just hit ok
and here's our output we have a whole
bunch of variables
and it tells us first the number of
observations at 6 400
almost all the way down this question
about internet is missing some data
but that appears to be the only one
we have the minimum value and the
maximum value by the way this is where i
talk about
quick and easy data checking if you have
a variable that's only supposed to go
from one to five or zero to one if you
have a 17 you know something's wrong
and so by simply checking the outer
boundaries
that's a fast way of seeing if there are
any really obvious errors
we also have the mean and the standard
deviation two of the things you
generally need the first two moments of
a distribution
and so that's a lot of information and
it's in a very concise format that's a
wonderful thing
if we go back to syntax i do want to
mention this one thing about indicator
variables i said it earlier
it's this if you have indicator
variables that's
a binary or dichotomous variable that
has only two possible values
and if that variable is coded as zero
and one
then you can in fact get the mean of it
and it tells you something that tells
you the proportion
of observations that have ones
and this works best if you use the
standard programmer format of zero
equals false or no and one equals true
or yes
and strangely in this particular data
set that's true for
most of the variables but not the last
one or two in demo.save and i have no
idea where they switched that
but it's something that you want to
check in the coding before you go ahead
and do it
and so if i go back to the output you
can see for instance that
most of these wireless service
down through owen's fax machine those
are all zero ones where zero is no and
one is yes
the mean right here tells us that 99
of the people own tvs 96 own vcrs
because this is a long time ago
that 25 had paging services
and i'd like this one where's the
internet on this list
27 had the internet because this was
apparently generated in like you know
1990 who knows what anyhow
those are meaningful data points the
mean tells you the proportion of ones or
yeses
i'll go back to the syntax here and then
let's take a quick look at the z
scores now any reasonable person would
think that a z score is a transformation
of the data and therefore it would be
under the transform
menu but you know what it's it's not
there
instead it's hidden as an option in
descriptives
so let's go back to descriptives
and let's do age and income so i'm going
to reset this
i'm going to pick age and i'm going to
pick household income
and i'm going to get both of these as z
scores because a lot of procedures
work a lot better if you have z-scores
all you have to do is this
click save standardized values as
variables
and if i hit ok
what it's done here is it gives me the
descriptives because i actually still
ran the descriptives command
for those two variables but more
significantly let's take a look at the
data set
when i come to the data set if i scroll
to the end here
i have two variables that were not there
previously z
age and z income and they have lots of
decimal places because you need those
with z scores
now i'm rephrasing now under normal
circumstances you would want to save
this into the data i'm not going to do
that because this is one of
sps's built-in default data sets
but i do want to show you that we can do
one other thing here let's go back and
get descriptives
for those z scores so i'm going to come
to analyze descriptives
i'm going to reset this come down to see
our two new variables
i'll select do a little shift click to
get both of them
then pop them over here then i'll hit ok
and as you would expect a z-score
has a mean of zero and a standard
deviation of one
and we didn't have to do it manually we
didn't have to remember any values we
didn't have to round things off
it did it exactly for us and so that is
what the descriptives command does it
makes a very concise tabular output
and it also allows you to save
standardized or z-scores
for use in certain procedures
for a final look in spss at basic
statistics we'll look at the explore
command
i like to think of this as a way to get
a lot closer get a little macro view on
your subject
get closer and see what's there in
detail
now the explore command is going to give
you a bunch of statistics it can give
you the mean
and the confidence interval for the mean
and the trimmed
mean as well as the variance the
standard deviation the interquartile
range the minimum and maximum
the range skewness kurtosis
a collection of m estimators which are
special robust ways for measuring the
center of a distribution
percentiles which we've seen before and
lists of outliers it can also
give you a collection of plots it's the
one place in spss that you can get a
stem and leaf plot
now traditionally those are things that
are drawn by hand so it's kind of cute
to see a computer do them
you can also get box plots and you can
get histograms
and you can get a set of normality plots
such as a q
q plot or a d trended qq plot
and the neat thing after that is you can
break all of these analyses down
by groups so let's try it in spss and
see how it works
just open up this syntax file and we'll
run through the various procedures and
explore and see how
it can add to your own analysis
as always we'll begin by opening the
demo.save
dataset here's the command for a mac
here's the command for windows
now again i'm saving this as syntax that
makes it repeatable and it means so you
can download it and try running it on
your own
but i created all of this by using the
menu commands
let's start by doing a default explore
analysis for a couple of variables
i'll come up to analyze to descriptives
and then we'll come here to
explore and what we're going to do is
age
and income category
and again this is kind of interesting
because these are different kinds of
variables
age is a scale variable an income
category in this case is an
ordinal variable i'm just going to leave
all the defaults as there and hit ok
and here's what we get from this first
we find out whether there were any
missing cases there weren't in this
situation and then we get a collection
of descriptive statistics for these we
have
first for age then for income category
we have the mean
with the standard error the confidence
intervals the five percent trimmed mean
median variance standard deviation
minimum maximum range interquartile
range
skewness and kurtosis along with their
standard errors and so there's a lot of
information there
and we scroll down we find the same
kinds of information for
income category in thousands now
remember
some of this you wouldn't normally want
to use because income category in this
case
is not a scaled variable and a lot of
these things
like minimum maximum and trim mean work
best with a scaled variable
but spss is able to kind of run it on
everything so
interpret with caution then we come down
and look we have a stem and leaf plot
where this is age which in our sample is
two digit numbers
and so this means 1 8 18
and each of these leaves each of these
numbers over here is a leaf
that represents 10 cases remember we
have 6 400 cases
so we have about 640 numbers right here
and you can see for instance that the
30s
appear really common late 30s and that
we go up to
somebody in their late 70s and so that's
an easy way
to see what's going on simultaneously we
get a box plot
and the nice thing about this is you can
tell really quickly there are no
outliers on age
not in this particular data set
we do the same thing with income
category and the stem and leaf plot
looks funny but that's because there's
only a few possible values one
or two or three or four and
it's drawing it so it looks a little
weird but we can come down and get the
box plot as well we see there's no
outliers at least
on this kind of variable again not
normally something you would do with a
rank order variable
but it's possible here
now the neat thing is there are
additional statistics i'll do the same
two statistics but i'm going to go check
off a lot of
options that i have right here so let's
go back to that
dialog i'll go to explore
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say just give me the statistics right
now
and i'll come up here and i'll make some
selections one thing
although 95 confidence intervals are by
far the most common
i have seen significant situations where
people used 80
confidence intervals so you can change
it if you want
then i can get all of the m estimators
it's a whole collection
i can get a list of outliers and a list
of percentile values
i hit continue and i click ok
and now we have the same table we had
before that's their descriptives up
there at top
then we have the m estimators and this
is four different robust measures of
center
again all of them are trying to give us
something equivalent to the mean
and you see in this case huber's m
estimator tukey's by weight hampels m
estimator and andrew's wave
the numbers are all pretty similar i
mean it goes from a low of 41.18 to a
high of 41.52
but they're all really close and each of
these has specific parameters that go
into them
you can't adjust them in the dialog box
but let me just return to the syntax for
one second
you see here these are the parameters
for each of the m estimators
you could change them here if you wanted
to
i'll go back to the output then we have
percentiles
5 10 25 up to 95 and then it gives us
the case numbers for the highest and
lowest five cases on each variable
and so this is a really nice way of
seeing
a multi-dimensional picture of our data
now in terms of pictures and even better
ways to do this with more graphs
so let me go back to the syntax for a
second
and you see that we can get some
additional plots
i'm going to use age and income category
again but i'm going to change
what it tells us so first off
i'm going to say give me just the plot
so we're not going to get any statistics
i'm come to the plots menu and i say
well we have a stem leaf by default
let's get a histogram
let's also get normality plots that's a
way of assessing how closely your data
match a normal distribution
i'll hit continue and okay
and now i have a histogram for age
the stem and leaf plot but this one here
is normal
but this one here is new it's a normal
qq or quantile quantile plot of age in
years
and if it were normally distributed all
of these circles would fall exactly on
this line
you see it's really close but it does
deviate at each end
and then a detrended one takes that line
and sort of flattens it out and it's
much easier to see where the changes are
now i know it looks really big in this
case but this variable is in fact
pretty close to a normal distribution
then we have our box plot
and then we do the same thing for income
we start with a histogram
our stem and leaf plot and our normal qq
plot again
a little weird because there's only four
possible values in this data set but
they all
fall pretty well on the line and there's
our
detrended plot and then finally the box
file that we saw before
now there's one more thing we can do
with the explore command and that is we
can take some of these analyses and
break them down by
groups so if we go back to the syntax
we'll see i'm going to do income and
break it down by gender
let's go back to the menu here go to
explore
and i'm going to reset this
and we're going to take income and put
that into our dependent or outcome
variable list or the thing that we're
trying to predict and then we'll take
gender scroll down a little bit there's
gender put into the factor list or
sometimes people call it independent
variables that's if it's an
experimentally manipulated variable
or the predictor variable now i'm going
to come up here and i'm actually going
to skip the statistics and get plots
only i don't want a stem-and-leaf but i
will get a histogram i'll get the
normality plots
and now because i'm breaking it down by
groups i can check the spread
versus level with levine test the idea
here is that the data should be spread
out approximately the same amount for
each of the groups so we can compare
them
using some uniform statistics i'm going
to do what's called a power estimation
here
click continue and then okay
and now what we get is again is a list
of the number of cases that have
complete data and then
all of them do there's no missing data
we have a test
of normality and what we see here is
based on both of these
that the data for neither group is
normal
that's okay because we knew that income
was strongly positively skewed
as for homogeneity of variance whether
the two groups have
about the same variance or spread
you know there is some difference but
they are not statistically significant
and so it appears to be the same for the
men and women which is good in this
particular data set
then we can come down and see the
histograms first for women and you see
it's
got a really strong skewness there and
the same thing again for men
really strongly skewed then we get
the normal qq or quantile quantile plots
and again if it were normally
distributed all of these points would
fall right on this line
it's strongly skewed and so we have this
really big bend in the data
the same is true for men and here's the
detrended lines where they should all be
flat on that line instead you get this
swoosh mark instead
and so it just confirms that we're not
dealing with normally distributed data
and what you do have is this big
collection
of outliers in the box plots i'm going
to do one thing i'm going to double
click on this
and then i'm going to come right up to
here and this will turn off the data
labels so we can get rid of the id
numbers and you can see that we have
a lot of outliers in both the men and
both the women and there's no really
obvious differences between the two
groups
and the spread versus level plot is
something that you can use if you have
multiple levels
that it can help you select a kind of
power transformation
a square root a reciprocal a square or
something like that
but that's a more complicated topic and
something for another day and besides
it appears that we have relatively
homogeneous
variants in the two groups and so we'd
be good to go ahead and do our other
analyses
and so those are some of the options and
explore and that's where we'll end our
discussion of
basic statistics but you can see how
they can be used
to see how well your data meet the
assumptions of the procedures that you
use
and then really how well you can make
inferences from your sample to other
groups
when you're working in spss and you're
accessing data
one of the most important things you can
do is to create
labels and definitions for your data
i like to think of this as the
statistical version of alice in
wonderland in the caterpillar
asking her to explain herself you need
to explain
yourself or more specifically when it
comes to your data
you need to tell spss what do your data
mean
now that is the data description and
i see two kinds of information that you
tell spss about your data
the first one i'm going to call
semiotics which comes from the study of
meaning this is where you tell spss
what the variable names are the data
types
the variable labels the value labels the
missing values
the level of measurement and the role
that each variable plays
contrasted with that there are other
elements that you can call
aesthetics and that addresses variable
width
decimal places column width and
alignment
and these are all settings within the
data window of spss
one of the most important though at
least for human consumption is going to
be
the variable and value labels and so i'm
going to take a little time and talk
about those
with the variable names that's what the
short names the ones that you have there
at the top of the column
there are some important rules so the
rules for variable names
number one the names must be unique no
two variables can have the same name
that shouldn't be too surprising it's an
identifier
rule number two the names must start
with the letter
i put an asterisk there because you can
start with an
at a pound sign or a dollar sign but you
don't want to because those are
generally reserved for special functions
within spss
rule number three names can use letters
upper lower case
they can use numbers and they can use
period underscore at pound dollar sign
on the other hand don't end with a
period that can cause confusion with the
command terminator
and don't end with an underscore because
that's used for automatic variable names
when
spss is doing computations rule number
four
names cannot include spaces and rule
number five
names must be less than 64 bytes
in most text coding systems
that's 64 characters but if you're using
the unicode system that might be only 32
characters
and the last rule rule number six is the
names cannot be
any of these words all and by eq g e gt
l e lt and e not or to or with
because those are all reserved function
names within
spss so don't create that confusion
so those are the short names that go at
the top of a variable
on the other hand the label that you
associate with that you can give it a
more descriptive name
those are the variable labels and so
there are a few rules for those
rule number one they must be less than
256 bytes that actually means it can be
really long although you don't usually
want to do that
because some procedures will display as
few as 40 bytes 40 characters
and you really want to be able to read
what it is so you want to keep it short
but you can go longer if you need to
rule number two the labels must be
enclosed in
quotes although i'll tell you they need
to be
straight quotes the vertical ones and
not the curly quotes
or spss chokes on those rule number
three
labels can include any character
including spaces which is something that
you can't have in the variable name but
you can put it here
so that allows you to put labels that
sort of float on top of the
variable names and those can show up in
the variable lists they can show up in
the
charts and the output that you create
another really important one is
value labels so you may have a variable
called gender and you may put
zeros and ones but do you remember what
those zeros and ones are and so i'm
going to show you some
ways of dealing with that the most
important thing is to put
value labels on there so here are the
rules for value labels
rule number one they must be less than
121 bytes so
that actually is really long you
generally want to keep your labels
pretty short
rule number two like the variable labels
the value labels must be enclosed in
quotes and they need to be the straight
quotes and not curly quotes
rule number three labels can include any
character including spaces
that's good this is an interesting one
rule number four
the value labels do not need to be
unique
that is more than one value can have the
same
label so you might have the numbers one
through nine
and it could be that seven eight and
nine all say
the same thing but they underneath have
different coding there are situations
where you might wanna do that
but mostly i want to show you how this
works in spss
so just open up this syntax file
and this one's going to be a little
different because we're actually not
going to use a data file i'll refer to
one but
i mostly just want to show you the
syntax
this syntax file shows how to write
variable labels and value labels now
you don't necessarily have to put them
all broken down in lines i do it because
it makes them a lot more readable it's a
lot easier to see what's going on
the first thing is the command variable
labels because it's an spss command it's
written on
all capitals and then what you do is you
write the
short name of the variable and then you
have at least one space
and then you have straight quotes and
then the long
label so here for instance i've got ver
0 1 that would be the first variable and
then
this is its label written out and you
don't need to have anything after don't
need
any commas or question marks or
semicolons or anything
you just go to the next one now i put it
into another line because that makes it
easy to follow
and i run them all through here i'm
going to make one
important recommendation if you have a
dichotomous variable or binary one that
has only two possible values
and gender might fit into that category
let me recommend this
that you code it as zeros and ones a lot
of people use ones and twos but that
gets confusing if you code it as zeros
and
ones and name the variable after
whatever the one
is now when it comes to male and female
i
generally give ones to whichever group i
think is going to have the higher score
on my main outcome variable
so it'll switch around but if for some
reason i think that
men are going to have a higher score on
an outcome variable
then i will call it male and then the
label will be
r for respondent is male on the other
hand if i think women are going to have
a higher score then i will call the
variable female and the label will be
r is female i would obviously only use
one of those two
now here are some other examples i
tend to give generic names such as
variable or really just q for question
q01q02
and i use the leading zeros so they sort
properly
in the dialog boxes and when you're done
listing all of your variable names and
the variable labels and quotes
just end with a period it doesn't have
to be have a space before that's
left over from earlier versions of spss
it's a habit i have
so you can run this at any time and it
will assign
these labels to the variables and then
they'll show up in the data file which
is nice
next are the value labels and
what you have here is the first command
which is written in all caps and then
you give a list of
variables to which the values apply
and you can list them out separately
ver1 verito
here i've got a vera 3 without a leading
zero
and then if they're all next to each
other if they
are adjacent they can actually specify
ranges
vera 3 2 and capitals verten so that'll
do 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
and then you just go to the next line
and you give the first
value that's a 0 and then i give 0
equals no and 1 equals yes when you're
done giving the values you need to put a
slash so it knows you're done with the
values for that variable
then you can go on to the next variable
i said for instance
if i gave 1 on a gender variable to men
i would call it male and so 0
which would mean no they're not male
would be female
and 1 yes they are or true that would be
male
you do a slash on the other hand if you
coded it the other way
then you just call it female and zero
which means no or false means
they're not female they're male 1 means
they are fine
obviously use just one of these i do the
slash
and then i could have a rating variable
say for instance a lot of people call it
a likert scale just a rating scale
and i could do rate 0 1 to rate 10
and i can specify every value so this is
a five point scale from strongly
disagree to strongly agree
finish with a slash or maybe have a
different kind of scale
here at the end i have scale zero one
through scale zero two
that's an eleven point scale but i only
mark the two ends the 0
and the 10. so 0 is never or not at all
10 is always completely
and then to let spss know that i'm done
specifying
value labels end with a period so this
is actually a single
sentence and it's a way of telling it
how you want the numbers to appear
both in the data window and in any
output that you get
finally i'll mention something about
missing values because it can also be
easier to specify these
in syntax the command is missing values
and you just give the names of the
variables and you can use two
in the same way and then in parentheses
you put the number
that is assigned to missing values 99's
common
so i've got that there and then you can
do a slash if you're going to use
different codes after that i could do
male through female
and here i say 2 through high and really
what that means is
anything other than a zero or a one is
missing
so if i accidentally type in a seven you
know it's missing
and then here i specify several
different values i can put seven
comma eight comma 9. so if any of those
show up
those would be considered missing values
do what you want the nice thing is
it will exclude them automatically from
analyses but it will include them in
frequencies when you're getting that
output finish with the period
and then you just run these like you do
any other command
and it's going to do a lot to clarify
your data and make it easier to follow
your analyses
and reconstitute your work in the future
you're working in spss and you're trying
to access data
you may get the idea of entering data
well let me tell you
my thoughts you want to enter data in
spss
i just see it as an exercise in
frustration
it's a pain to do it manually and i'd
say maybe if you're entering
10 or 12 numbers you know basically
nothing
it's something that's often referred to
as a toy data set
maybe you could do that now it's also
possible to
copy and paste data but i'm going to say
sort of because it doesn't work really
well i'll show you that
it's much much easier to just import the
data from a csv file or text file and
i'll show you how to do that in the next
section but in terms of entering data
let me show you how it works in spss
we'll just open up a blank document
and we'll try it so here's a blank
data window in spss i can come right
here and i can enter a number
and you know unfortunately if i press
tab it actually goes down which is an
unusual behavior
and you see it gives it an automatic
variable name var0001
well if i want to move sideways i
actually need to move the right arrow
key
so i'll go this way 2 3 and so on
and then i can hit return and it goes
down i'll come back to here and i'll go
4 5 six i'll hit
tab and it comes back to the beginning
so
it's not the most intuitive behavior
plus you see it gives it these generic
names that's because you can't enter the
variable name directly in this window
instead what you have to do is go to
variable view
you can also get there by just double
clicking on the variable name
here we go and you can enter the
variable name and you can change other
things you want to do
it works but it's a pain i want to come
back here to data view
now i mentioned you can import data
sort of so let me show you how this
works i'm actually going to go to
a google sheet that has nothing in it at
the moment
and here i'm going to enter a few values
of a few different kinds i'll do 56 43
and i'll enter a number j
return i'll go
okay so there's some data i've got two
digit numbers and i have
letters which will be string variables
in spss i'm going to
copy those
and we'll see how well they paste over
in spss so i'm going to go back there
i'll come over here to the side and i
will
paste those in and
you see that the values came in and
showed up with decimal places and i can
get rid of that
but it's really weird with the string
variable
with the letters and so you can copy it
notice also i can't copy in variable
names i still have to enter those
manually
you can deal with those when you import
but really this is a demonstration that
putting stuff manually in spss it's not
a good environment for that
use a spreadsheet use google sheet use
numbers use excel anything enter it
there and then
import it i'll show you that in the next
section and you'll see that it's a much
much easier process
the last thing i want to say in spss
about accessing data
is about importing data and you know
compared to entering it
manually it just makes me feel like this
and i resort to cheesy clipart to show
how happy i am because no doubt about it
importing is absolutely the best way to
go if you want to get data into spss
now the nice thing is spss can open text
files it can open csv or comma separated
value files
and even xlsx that's excel files
as long as they're formatted right now
what do i mean by formatted write
there's a term
from hadley wickham in the r developer
community
tidy data and it's referring to
something very specific
it says that your file should have only
one sheet so that's one worksheet even
though excel can take
more than that that each column should
be exactly equal
to one variable and that each row should
be
equal to one case and
an important thing is no funny stuff in
your excel sheet because
excel is very flexible and when i refer
to funny stuff i'm talking about things
like
macros and formulas and graphs and
formatting and comments or merged cells
or headers taking up their own rows or
duplicating row numbers you don't want
any of that
basically you want to treat it like a
csv file
and if you do that then you find you can
import it very easily into spss
and in fact let me show you how this
works we're going to try this in spss
but i want you to do
two things first i want you to download
the course files and that will include a
zipped
folder by this name that ends with data
sets
that's going to have three files inside
it
i'll show you those in just a second and
then you can also open up
this syntax file that will work with
them
but let's go to see what's inside the
folder
and explain a little bit what's going to
happen here
the folder that i've asked you to
download contains three different
files now i have both the folder here
and i have the three files saved
separately next to it but normally they
would be inside it
but for the syntax to work properly you
want them sitting separately on the
desktop
all three of them contain the same data
it says mbb
which stands for mozart beethoven mbok
because this is
google trends data about the popularity
of search for each of these three
composers names
since 2004. this first one is in csv or
comma separated value format
the second one is a plain text file and
it's
tab separated and the third one
is an xlsx file so it's an excel sheet
and you can see it's the same number but
it appears a little bit differently when
i do the quick view here on my macintosh
what we're going to do then is open up
the syntax file
and we're going to see what we need to
do to import each of these now
i've saved the syntax but the fact is
it's easier to do this stuff
through the menus now i give some
information here about
using the file path in each of these
syntax commands
i have to specify the file location
now this is the format if you're on a
macintosh like i am
of course you'll want to change bart to
be the name of your home directory
if you're on a windows computer you're
going to need to change it to something
a little more like this
or possibly depending on the version of
your operating system
using backslashes instead anyhow
i'm going to show you how to import each
of these and
i've got the duplicate information here
in the script in case you want to run it
that way but it's actually really easy
to do it
from the menus so here's what i'm going
to do i'm going to come up
to my data window i'll just click over
to that
and my data window is empty right now
i'm going to go to file
open and data you do that if you're
opening an existing sps file or if
you're importing something in a
different format
now here i'm on the desktop you can see
my folder there but you can't see the
three data files i have next to it
because right now
it's only going to display files that
are in the dot save that's the spss
proprietary data format
i'm going to click on that and come way
down here and we'll start with
the text file the txt version so i'm
going to hit that
and now you can see that it's there i'll
select that file and i'll click
open
so now i have the spss text import
wizard
and we can scroll through most this
pretty quickly it asks if it matches a
predefined format something i would have
saved somewhere else it doesn't
it asks if they're delimited yes they're
delimited by tabs in this case
are the variables included at the top of
the file you see how they show up here
as the first
row well i click yes and now it excludes
us because it knows that those need to
be the
in the header of the data file hit
continue
each line represents a case i want all
of the cases
you could sample from it if you had a
very large data set and it would allow
you to do
exploratory analyses more quickly than
you could otherwise
and that's what delimiters appear now by
default a
text file the one that i have uses tabs
in it knows that
it asks about text qualifiers i don't
have text qualifiers in here so i just
hit continue don't have to change
anything
now i have dates here at the beginning
and
they are year dash month now
spss can handle dates however it doesn't
like the fact that i'm using year and
month without the day associated with it
consequently i'm going to leave it just
as a string variable as a text variable
and it still works properly in any
analyses i want to do so that's fine
i'm just going to hit continue not
changing anything here
it asks if i'd like to save the file
format for future use that's the thing
it was referring to in the first
dialog here and that's if i want to
paste the syntax i could do that but
i've already got it pasted
i'm just going to hit done
and there it is it's opened it up and
it's formatted properly
if we go to variable view you can see
it's got
a string variable it's got three numeric
variables it has the proper number of
digits
it has the proper number of no decimal
places
and it recognizes them as nominal which
actually
is not the case so i actually need to
come here
and change that to a scaled variable
because the data that you get from
google trends is sort of zero to one
percentages in terms of
relative popularity of search terms do i
change that to
scale and otherwise i'm good to go
now let's do the same thing but with a
csv file
to do that i'm just going to get rid of
this data file i'll just open up a new
one
there we go i'll come back up to the
file
and open to data
this time i need to tell i'm looking for
a csv but remember
that's actually under text so i click
here
and except this time instead of
selecting the dot txt file i'll select
the dot csv
file and what you find is that the
procedure is
almost identical there's only one super
tiny change here
i hit continue i tell the variable names
are at the top
it is delimited it needs to know that
each line's a case i just hit continue
on all of this
here's the one difference when i did the
text file tab
was automatically selected now that i'm
doing a csv which means comma separated
values
comma is automatically selected i hit
continue
it does the same thing with month we're
going to leave it as string i hit
continue
and i can hit done
and you see it looks exactly the same i
do have the same issue though
that these three numbers which go from 0
to 100 are coded as nominal i need to
change them
manually to scale
great and now we'll do the third one
an excel file now in a lot of programs
you get very stern warnings about
importing excel files and there's good
reasons for that
because excel files are very flexible
and people can put a lot of stuff in
there
again comments and changing column
widths and merging cells
that make it easy to use excel just for
displaying information but if you're
importing
you don't want to do that fortunately i
have it set up as tidy data already
columns are the same as variables rows
are the same as cases there's nothing
else in there
and so what i can do in this case is
come to file
open we'll go to data again
and this time i come down to this one it
actually has
excel file as a format
there it is i'll hit open and you'll see
that the dialog is different in this
case
it says opening excel data source
instead of the text import wizard
it says read the variable names from the
first row that's checked by default
it knows how many rows of data i have
and it's got this thing about maximum
width i don't need to worry about that i
just hit ok
and that was that here's the data from
excel
it's the same data i still need to
change these three measures
manually you could save this information
in syntax if you're going to be doing it
many times over
but that is sufficient for what i need
and so it turns out that importing
information into spss is really
easy and it's massively
more efficient and easier to do than
entering it directly
you do it in a spreadsheet especially if
you do it on google sheets if you're
entering stuff manually you can
collaborate on it
and then you save it as a csv file and
you pop it in there
and then you can get straight to your
analysis and that is the point of all
this work anyhow
and now in spss and introduction we get
to the part that
maybe you were waiting for and that's
analyzing data
i'll mention however i'm going to give
only a very
small overview of analyzing data because
we have an entire separate course here
for data analysis and also data
visualization
in spss and i recommend that you check
those out but as a
taste of what's available we'll talk
about a procedure that's of interest to
a lot of people in applied settings
and that's hierarchical clustering
now the idea here is that you're trying
to find clusters
you're trying to find the clusters in
your data more specifically what you're
trying to see
is whether similar cases cluster
together
in some way that you can use to make
inferences about them
the trick however is that similarity
depends on your criteria
and there's a few decisions that you
have to make when you're doing a cluster
analysis of any kind
so for instance you have to decide
whether you're going to do a
hierarchical cluster analysis
which goes from one group to as many
groups as you have cases
or whether you're going to use a set k
or set
number of clusters you also have to
decide on the measures of distance that
you're going to use
euclidean distance which is sort of like
measuring the
as the crow flies distance between cases
is very common as is
squared euclidean distance which is what
spss uses
there's also the question of whether you
want to start with everything together
and split it up in a divisive procedure
or start with everything separate and
put it together in an agglomerative
procedure by default some programs like
r
do divisive but by default spss
does agglomerative you basically end up
with the same
general findings anyhow so it's really
not a huge difference
so we're going to do a cluster analysis
but we're going to try to keep it simple
we're going to use some of the most
basic methods for doing this we'll use
euclidean distance or square euclidean
distance in this case
we'll use hierarchical clustering where
we don't have to choose the number of
groups ahead of time
and we're going to use an agglomerative
procedure where it starts with every
case
separate and then gradually puts them
together
we'll try this in spss but i need you to
do something first
there is a folder that you can download
from the case files
that ends with data here and in it
there's one file
it's cars.save where sav
is the proprietary spss data format
and in addition to that there is the sps
syntax file and you'll want both of
those for this demonstration
if you save the data file to your
desktop
it looks like this you can just double
click on it and it will open up in spss
you also have the option of using syntax
to do that
it depends on your operating system this
is for a macintosh right here
and this is for a windows computer
though you may need to use backslashes
instead depending on your version of
windows
i'm just going to go back and double
click on this
to open it up in spss
and there's my data set what this data
set is
is a slight variation on a data set
called
mt cars that's in the default data sets
package in
r it contains road test data on a number
of cars from 1974
from the magazine motor trend and what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at this information and we're going to
see
whether the car is clustered together in
some important way
i'll go to the data view here and you
can see we have mazda rx4
hornet sportabout mercedes 450se
lincoln continental and so on cars that
were all available in the early 70s
and we have information about miles per
gallon
we have the cylinders we have the
displacement in cubic inches horsepower
weight in tons quarter second time in
the standing quarter mile
whether it's an automatic or a manual
transmission the number of gears in the
transmission
and the number of carburetors are
probably carburetor barrels here
i'm going to turn on the labels only one
variable changes here
by the way one of the things i did is i
formatted this for spss by adding labels
and changing some of the decimals and
makes it a little easier to work with in
the program
but let's go to the syntax file right
now
once we have the data open we want to do
a default
hierarchical clustering now this is the
code to produce it right here
but i'm going to do it with the drop
down menus to show you that it's really
not hard to do
all we need to do is come up to analyze
and then we come down to classify
now i have to admit off the top of my
head i cannot remember if
every version of spss has this
particular menu
most will i hope yours does so you can
follow along with this
hierarchical cluster i'm going to click
on that
and what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to take car name
which really tells me it just says what
the cars are
and i'm going to use that to label cases
because that's going to mean something
to me
and i'm going to take all of my other
variables i'll just do a little shift
click here
and put them over here and at this
moment i'm going to change
nothing else you'll see that it's going
to cluster cases that's what we want
it's going to give us both some
statistics and some plots
that's fine i'm going to hit ok and
we're going to get a result
identical to my first syntax command
i see it sound i'll make the output
window bigger here
and here's what we have first off it
tells us how many cases there were there
were 32 and they all had complete data
which is nice
then spss gives us something kind of
unusual called an agglomeration
schedule and it really specifies at what
point in the
procedure did two cases get put into the
same cluster
i personally don't have much use for
this except i know that when there is a
big jump in the coefficients as there is
here from 3
to 26 you know that there is a very
distinct
category change as there is from 660 to
11 25 and so on
most of the time though i would just
completely ignore this one
and this this is called an icicle plot
and it
shows sort of the same information about
when various cases got
dropped in with everything else it's
kind of pretty to look at
i find it kind of meaningless and so
truthfully
the default output for spss hierarchical
clustering to me is not very helpful
in fact it's so unhelpful i'm just going
to delete it all
and i'm going to do this over again i'm
going to come back up to my recent
menu items and i'm going to go to this
analysis again i'm going to make a
couple of changes
i don't want the agglomeration schedule
that doesn't really help me
and for plots i'm going to get rid of
the icicle plot
and i'm going to get a dendrogram
instead
dendrogram that means branches in greek
so it's a graph of the branches
and this is usually the most important
thing you can get out of a hierarchical
cluster analysis
i'll hit okay
and now what we have
is a chart here that lists all the cases
the car is on the side
and it shows how they group together
so we see for instance that these first
four cars the mazda rx-4 and the wagon
and the mercedes 280 and 280c
are very similar to one another they all
go here together
we see that some others if we come down
here
so for instance the cadillac fleetwood
the lincoln continental and the chrysler
imperial which are all gargantuan
american cars with big v8s they all go
there together
and then we see down here at the bottom
that this one the maserati bora is all
by itself for a very long time
this is where cases are individual here
on the left and they
gradually get put together and you see
how they
come together in each of these branches
that's why it's called a dendrogram
and so this is a really nice way of
seeing how similar your cases are
and if you have more pixels displayed
you can see the entire graph at once
i've got a
low resolution right here and you can
see that
maybe it makes sense to split this off
into say
four groups looks like we've got a
distinct group right here right there
right there and right there and so i can
do something else with this
i'm going to come back to the menu here
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
save group membership
now i've done a hierarchical analysis so
i didn't have to specify the number of
groups but now that i've looked at the
chart
4 seems like a good number so i'm going
to come here and say
give me the group membership for each
case
breaking it down into four clusters
i'll hit continue and i'm going to ask
for it to not give me any plots
i hit okay and this time
we're not going to get any output except
to say that it did the work
let's just get that here it says that it
processed them
the place where we're going to see the
difference is in the data file so i'm
going to move over to the data file
this button by the way will get me over
to the data
and now you can see i have a new
variable that got added here
for clusters four and you can see that
each of the cars is listed in one of
these four
clusters and what you can do then
is you can then take these cluster
memberships
and you can compare them on the other
variables again remember
the clustering here is only as valid as
the data that we give it
so it's only comparing these cars on a
small number of variables
and it's using that to decide what goes
with what it's here for instance that
you see the
maserati bora is in a category all by
itself
and this is a neat way of looking at the
similarity between items you can do it
with
people if you're doing market research
you can do with companies if you're
doing some sort of segmentation
and it allows you to see what groups
have
important similarities for what your
purposes are
and which groups you need to treat
differently as one another
that's the goal of hierarchical
clustering analysis and you find it's a
very easy thing to do in spss
another important procedure in spss when
you're analyzing data
is something called factor analysis now
i like to think of it
as looking at your data and trying to
find shadows
in this picture what you have are
shadows those are the
black figures that you see it takes a
moment to figure out that you're looking
down and there actually are
people but kind of sticking straight out
and so
in this photo where you're going from is
sort of a three dimensional origin
that's the person itself
to a two dimensional variation with the
shadow what's interesting about that
is you maintain most of the useful data
you can tell that they're people that
they're walking you can probably even
tell some things about how tall they are
what they're wearing and so on
what you've done is you've made things
more efficient
now in the data world that's called
dimensionality
reduction where each variable is a
dimension
and too many variables can actually be
really problematic
you're trying to boil things down a
little bit
and you can think about this saying less
is more less equals more
more specifically that is less noise
and fewer unhelpful variables in your
data set
equal more meaning because that's what
you're trying to do you're trying to
extract
meaning now when it comes to factor
analysis and related techniques
i have one very important piece of
advice and that is to be
practical at all points you want to
remember
what is your goal so what is the goal
well the goal of factor analysis i'll
tell you what it's
not it's not an exercise in analytical
purity you're not there to show that you
know how to go through all the steps in
the approved format
really you're working with your data
because you're trying to get
some understanding so the goal of a
procedure
like factor analysis is useful insight
try to follow the rules do what you can
to make sure you don't make any obvious
mistakes
but remember you're not bound by the
mathematics you're bound by what the
data tells you about the people
another way of looking at that is use
factor analysis
or really any other procedure for its
heuristic value
that is it suggests possibilities to you
as you analyze the data
as you're trying to get insight to
people now
that's sort of a philosophical
discursion let me show you how this
actually works in spss you're going to
need to download
from the course files a folder that says
data here at the end
and from it the cars.save
dataset this is the one that we used in
hierarchical clustering as well
and then you want to open up the spss
syntax file
that goes with this particular section
now the easiest way to open the data set
is simply to
double click on it and you'll be ready
to go i do have some syntax you can use
if you've saved it to your desktop
i've got it open already so let's take a
quick look at the data set
we have a collection of cars listed down
the side and
attributes like miles per gallon and so
on and gears and the transmission and
carburetors
that's great now i will have to make a
very important
confession here this is a very very
small data set for factor analysis
it only has nine variables other than
the identifier
and it only has 32 cases
really you would want to have at least
several hundred cases and
let's say several dozen variables
before you can do this really reliably
but this example
works and it it actually is really easy
to see how it's happening
and how to interpret the results the
first thing we're going to do
if you look at the syntax is we're going
to do a default
factor analysis and it's actually a
misnomer because it's not a factor
analysis
it's principal components analysis but
it's in the factor analysis
command within spss so let's come up
here to analyze
and down to dimension reduction remember
i said that's what this is called
we'll pick factor it's our only choice
there
and what we need to do is choose the
variables that we're going to use
to see what we can compress what goes
into what so we don't need the name of
the car that's just an identifier
we can take the rest of these however
and we can put them
under variables now
we've got a lot of options here i'm not
going to do any of them i'm just going
to hit
ok for right now
i'll make the output window bigger and
here's what we get from the default
analysis we get a
text output of the commands that were
generated by the drop-down menus
we get something called communalities
each variable
brings with it one unit of standardized
variance that's based on how spread out
the scores are
and if you standardize them then you
have a variance and a standard deviation
of one for each
and the extraction tells us how much of
that variance is really able to get
constituted through the
process that we're doing an important
one right here is the total
variance explained because what this has
done is it has created components
remember i said this is actually a
principle components analysis here
which while it has profoundly different
philosophical underpinnings from factor
analysis
the difference has to do with which came
first the factors or the observed
variables and
truthfully most people treat them as
relatively interchangeable and if you're
using them for
heuristic value it's not going to be a
big difference
but what we have here are two components
we have one with 5.472
units of variance that's 61 percent of
the original variance of the nine
variables
and then another one with 2.341 i'm
getting those numbers from right here
and you can see it held onto these two
which collectively
add up to about 87 percent of the
variance
now the component matrix shows the
relationship between the original
variables and the two components these
are like correlation coefficients
you can see that miles per gallon is
strongly negatively associated with the
first component
and really not associated with the
second
but number of carburetors has a pretty
strong association with each
and so that's a way to start to look at
it
but it's going to be a lot easier if we
do
certain modifications to this in fact
i'm going to just delete this output
right here
and we're going to start over i'm going
to make a few changes
let's go through each of these options
first we go to descriptives and i don't
really feel like i need the initial
solution so i'm going to unselect
that i'll hit continue
extraction this is the actual algorithm
that spss uses to work through the
relationships in the multi-dimensional
space
you'll see right here it's principal
components that's why i said this is
really a principal components analysis
you've got a lot of options here now in
many situations maximum likelihood would
be a very good answer
i'm going to choose principle access
factoring simply because it's the
classical version of factor analysis
i don't need to see the unrotated factor
solution but i do want to see something
called a scree
plot and that is a
graph that shows me maybe how many
factors i should keep
i'm going to come down here and change
the
maximum iterations for convergence that
has to do with the
math that's done i'm going to change it
to 50.
then i'm going to come to rotation what
you get here is a multi-dimensional
space and sometimes it's a little
easier if you rotate the axes
it can increase interpretability now
there are a lot of different methods
varimax is a method
that maintains orthogonal relationships
that makes
all of your axes perpendicular to each
other there are situations where that's
really good but truthfully
for exploratory purposes which is what
we're doing i like to use what's called
an oblique rotation
that allows your factors to be
correlated with each other they don't
have to be totally perpendicular i'm
going to use
direct ablamen promax is another really
good choice but it usually
is for larger data sets and i've got a
tiny one here
now here i can get a rotated solution i
don't think i really need that but i do
want to see the loading plot
and i'm going to increase the maximum
number of iterations to 50.
i'll hit continue we'll come down to
scores
and you can save the
factor loadings as scores there might be
situations which you want to do that
but because i'm using factor analysis
for its heuristic value as a way of
suggesting what variables go with others
i'm actually not going to do that so i'm
going to hit cancel
and then finally options this is where
you get to talk about
excluding cases i have a complete data
set so i don't need to worry about that
but the coefficient display format now
i'm going to sort it and then i'm
actually going to have it completely
erase small coefficients now i've done
this one before
so i happen to know that a value of 0.6
under normal circumstances that's really
high but given my very small data set
this seems like a reasonable choice and
it makes the solution
very very clear when we look at it so
i'm going to hit continue
and then there i'm going to hit ok
i've got my output here
and the first part is pretty similar
except it doesn't start with the unit
variance for each of these that's
because i'm not doing principal
components anymore i'm doing
principal axis factoring and so
the math behind it's a little bit
different but we don't need to dwell on
that one
total variance explained you see that we
still have two
factors and the first one accounts for a
lot of the variance the second one
accounts for
a fair amount also and these are very
close to what we had with the principal
components
the scree plot is a very simple line
plot that suggests how many factors we
might want to keep
now there are several different rules
you can use for interpreting this
one is anything that's above a value
of one because one is what it would be
if a variable explained
simply one unit of variance but that's
what it brought with it you want factors
that can explain
more than that and you see we have two
that do a lot more than one these others
are sort of straggling down the other
rule is to look for
a bend in the line and you do see a
strong bend right here
so three is where the bend is we're
justified in staying with two
there are other methods that get more
involved about checking for the slope of
this line and finding things that are
above that slope
you can do those at another time this is
a quick demonstration
now what we get next are three matrices
we get a factor matrix a
pattern matrix and a structure matrix
they're all associated with each other
and i've got a little note here in the
syntax that explains them
i'll come down here the factor matrix
is the association of each variable with
each factor and it's
similar in nature it's analogous to r
the correlation coefficient
that's the one that we're going to be
focusing on the structure matrix tells
us
how much each variable is predicted by
the factors because the idea here is
that factors come first and variables
come
second using what are called the unique
and common contributions so a factor
might contribute something
on its own compared to the other factors
or it contributes together
and then the pattern matrix is an
indication of each
factor's unique contribution to a
variable's variance those can both be
important in different situations they
can help you interpret things but for
right now i'm just going to focus on
this first one
there we go the factor matrix so let me
go back to where i was
and when we come up to the factor matrix
what you see here is because i suppress
values with an absolute value of less
than 0.6 we have this totally clear
separation
factor 1 is strongly associated with
the number of cylinders in the car
so more cylinders higher on factor one
and then displacement very high miles
per gallon
is negative but very strong and then we
have
weight in tons very strong in horsepower
this is really the
big factor cars that are really big are
going to score
heavily on factor one
factor two is composed of the number of
gears more years
the quarter mile time so the less time
it takes to get through the quarter mile
that is the faster it is
that's because it's negative here the
higher it is
automatic or manual you have to know
that zero is
automatic and one is manual so these are
manual transmission cars and those with
more carburetors
this is really the fast factor
and that's where sports cars are going
to this one this one has the cadillacs
and the lincoln's and this one has
the ferraris and the lotuses and and so
on
and that makes perfect sense it's really
easy to see
why that would be the way it is
and then if you come down here this plot
is also really helpful it's got the two
factors we have factor one across the
bottom
that's our big factor and you can see
that weight
goes on that one displacement goes on
that one cylinder
and then we have number of gears and
miles per gallon obviously you're on the
low end
factor two is the fast factor more
carburetors more horsepower and more
cylinders
and lower quarter mile times
and that makes a lot of sense and so
this lets us know that we could
boil down our data to really adjust
these two factors sort of how
big is the car and how fast is it
and that can give us a much more concise
image of our data and allows us to
extract more meaning
and that is the overall purpose of a
procedure like factor analysis or
principal components in spss
for a final look at spss and analyzing
data at least in this
brief overview course let's take a look
at one of the most useful procedures
around
regression now you might think of
regression as sort of the statistical
version of
the three musketeers where it's all for
one
i say that because all for one is
actually all variables
for predicting one outcome
put another way regression uses many
different variables many predictor
variables
to predict scores on one outcome
variable
this makes it useful in a huge range of
circumstances especially because
there's something for everyone with
regression there are
many different versions of it and many
adaptations of regression
that make it truly flexible and
powerful when analyzing data and make it
a go-to
tool for almost any analytical purpose
you might have
we'll try a simple version of this in
spss
first make sure you've downloaded this
data folder from the course files
and we'll use the cars.save dataset that
we've used in our two previous examples
along with this syntax file
now when you get to the syntax file it
begins as usual
with the code for loading the data set
from the desktop
truthfully it's easier to just double
click on the file cars.save and have it
open it up
directly in spss that's what i've done
here
and you can see it's the same data set
with about
32 rows of data a bunch of cars from
1974
and several variables what we're going
to try to predict in this one is
miles per gallon based on things like
the number of cylinders the displacement
horsepower
weight quarter second time transmission
and kind and gears and carburetors
all right so that should be pretty easy
what we're going to do
is go to analyze
and come down to regression and we'll
use
this second option here linear that's
just basic linear regression
now we need to put under dependent the
outcome variable the thing we're trying
to predict
kind of bugs me here because independent
and dependent really should be reserved
for
manipulated experiments but we still
know what they mean
our outcome variable the thing that
we're trying to predict goes here
independent
so that's miles per gallon and then we
can take everything else except car name
that's just a
label we'll take all the rest of these
and we'll put them under our independent
or
the variables that we are using to
predict the outcome
now i want to do the totally default no
extra steps version
first so i've put the variables in their
respective place
and i'll just hit ok
and now we get our output and it tells
us
first the code that was used to produce
this analysis
that it used all of these variables
simultaneously
to predict a single outcome which is
listed down here
and they were entered at once the model
summary tells us that we have a multiple
correlation
of these predictor variables with our
outcome variable of 0.931 which is
really really high if you square that to
get the proportion of variance explained
it's 86.7 percent
even the adjusted r squared because we
have a small sample
it's still 82 it's it's huge
we get a significance test right here we
are not surprised to see that the
significance is point zero zero zero
it's not zeros all the way through but
it's it's
highly significant and then we get
coefficients for the
individual regression coefficients
so what we're looking for here are
significance levels that are
under o5 and interestingly only one of
them
in this collection is under o5 and
that's
weight in tons none of the others are
there close
that doesn't mean that none of the
others matter it simply means that when
you take
all of the variables together at the
same
time when they are taken as a whole
really only one of them deviates
significantly from zero to become
a predictor that's a weight now
there are a lot of other ways of doing
regression
and spss gives you a lot of choices
i'm going to come up here back to
analyze
down to regression now i will mention
there's a really
interesting one here called automatic
linear modeling
this is a spss function that came in a
few versions ago
it does a lot of automatic data prep it
does a lot of
combining and splitting up the variables
on the other hand
it's really kind of difficult to explain
how it all works and then to interpret
it properly
and i'm going to save that for another
course where i specifically talk about
analyzing data
for now i'm going to go back to linear
and we're going to make a few choices
we're going to make a
few options rephrase
and we're going to make a few choices
we're going to take some of the options
that spss makes available
now the first one i'm going to do at the
risk of doing something very
controversial
is i'm actually going to go from
simultaneous entry
to stepwise regression this is
controversial because
some people in the literature have
called it positively diabolic
in its risk of a type one or false
positive error and there's good evidence
for that
on the other hand in modern machine
learning
stepwise procedures have been very
fruitfully used and so
it's not totally unacceptable to try it
especially when we're doing sort of an
exploratory project
like this right now you certainly
wouldn't want to use it for
rigorous model building but is a nice
way to get some insight into the data
pretty quickly
i'll come up to statistics and i'm going
to add a few things i'm going to get
confidence intervals for the
coefficients those are nice to have
we have the overall model fit and i'm
going to get the r squared change
because a stepwise model goes through
several different steps adding variables
and we want to see if each variable adds
something that is statistically
significant to the overall model
we could get a lot more information here
but i'll leave it there for now
under plots we can get a ton of
different plots but i'm actually just
going to come down here and choose the
standardized
residual plots a histogram and a normal
probability plot
now there are other options as well i
could save
about 15 different kinds of scores to
the data set
i can save unstandardized predicted
values i can save studentized deleted
residuals
and so on and so forth things i could do
here and there are situations in which i
might want to do those
but for right now i'm going to skip them
because i'm simply trying to build a
model without necessarily
saving all of the steps in between
options really just talks about the
criteria used
in the stepwise procedure i'm going to
leave it at the default right now but
you could change it if you wanted to
and then style is a new thing that has
to do with the formatting of the table
i'm going to leave that one alone for
right now because we're going to have
exactly what we need
now i've created this already and i've
saved it in the syntax so i'm just going
to hit
ok and you'll see that we get a
different kind of output right now
i'll zoom in on this
now what we have is some code that's a
little bit longer this has to go through
the variables one at a time
and find the predictor variable that is
most strongly associated with the
outcome
put it in the model get partial
correlations and
and go through step after step what we
find here is that
although we had nine predictors
originally only two of them were
statistically significant when put into
the model
they were weight and number of cylinders
again what we're trying to predict is
gas mileage miles per gallon
if you come down here you can see that
they were both statistically significant
where the adjusted r squared for just
weight is
74.5 and when you add on
number of cylinders it goes up not a
huge amount
but it goes up almost eight percent
the analysis of variance table lets us
know that both of these models with just
one variable and with two predictor
variables they're both statistically
significant
here the individual coefficients along
with their
confidence intervals over here on the
right side
now because we've gone through a
stepwise procedure it's not surprising
that all of these are statistically
significant because
that was the criterion used for
including them
here we have a list of excluded
variables along with their co-linearity
statistics and this has to do with
how much each of these variables is
correlated with the others so for
instance
number of carburetors is highly
co-linear
or easily predicted by the other
variables that we could have included in
the model
and then we come down to the residuals
i'm going to look specifically at the
charts
in an ideal world your residuals are
normally distributed which means they're
just as likely to be high as they are
low and they're symmetrical
and we see here that they're not
horribly
pathologically far from normal so this
is probably a good
model in this set and here is a normal
pp probability probability plot of the
same
data and if it were perfectly normal all
the dots would be on the
line the diagonal line they're close
these are the 32 individual observations
and how far off they're
they're close enough and so this lets us
know that our model is predicting really
well
and it appears to be not biased
in one direction or another so this is
one method of developing the model
again the stepwise procedure is best for
exploratory analyses it's not something
you would use for confirming a finding
but as a quick way of sifting through a
large collection of potential variables
this is a nice way to do it it lets us
know for instance
that in this particular data set miles
per gallon
is predicted primarily by a weight which
completely makes sense about the car
and number of cylinders which is
associated with having a large
and thirsty engine so
the general idea of multiple regression
again is to use
many variables to predict a single
outcome spss gives a lot of options for
those we've looked at the default we
looked at one variation on there
but there's a lot more that you can
explore and that we will cover in
another course on statistical analysis
in spss
but for now i encourage you to take some
time and look at some of these options
and see the kind of insight that they
can give you on your own data
and see what options you can use to get
useful
insight into your own analyses
i want to thank you for joining me in
spss an introduction
and we'll conclude by giving you some
next steps things that you can do next
because you know
once you get through this it can be a
little confusing feel like things are
going everywhere
and it may not be totally clear where
you should go
well here at datalab.cc we've got a few
opportunities for you
first of course is more spss we have
additional courses on
data preparation on data visualization
on statistical analysis and other topics
that you can use
to expand what you've learned in this
introductory course and work on your own
data
now if you've liked what you've learned
with spss you may want to try branching
out to some other languages
the statistical programming language r
and the general purpose programming
language python
are very common powerful tools in the
data science community in analytics in
general
they're a great way to expand both the
things that you can do with your
analyses and your employment
opportunities and so
i strongly encourage you to take a look
at the courses on r and python at
datalab
next we have specific courses on data
visualization one of the most important
things you can do
in getting to understand your data spss
can work well in those
as well as other programs and then i'm
going to mention
one final thing here spss is a wonderful
program
but it still has a fair amount of bugs
and it can also be very expensive
fortunately some really interesting work
recently in the open source community
has developed a program called jasb it's
actually pronounced
jasp which is sort of an open source
version of spss it runs very differently
i find it
very easy to use and it makes it
reproducible it makes it easy to share
it's got some tremendous advantages and
we have courses on jasp here at datalab
i suggest you check those out and see
how well that program is able to fulfill
some of your computing needs that being
said there are some things missing
what's missing exactly well spss
doesn't have a really strong and active
user and developer community the same
way that
languages like r and python do but
if you're creative you can get around
that academic conferences
meaning specifically topical academic
conferences like biology or management
or the social sciences
they often have very dedicated spss
users
and teachers and may sponsor specific
hands-on workshops
for learning more about spss and how you
can use it within your particular domain
but no matter what you do i'm going to
encourage you to simply
get started go exploring and see what
you can do with spss in your own day to
work
thanks so much for joining me and happy
computing